liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger liebe
landsleute hallo internet rolle liegt
ihnen die weihnachtsgans auch noch so
schwer im magen
meiner war dieses jahr begann ich habe
einfach blumenkohl und fleischlose
buletten zusammengelegt mit rosenkohl
befüllt und für acht stunden in den ofen
gesteckt das ganze habe ich mit
essigreiniger runtergespült das hat
scheiße geschmeckt aber es passte
einfach super um abschied zu nehmen von
wer in diesem jahr als promi nicht
gestorben ist der muss sich doch fragen
was habe ich falsch gemacht und jetzt
wartet 2017
die briten gehen dafür kommt donald
trump der adventskalender kam mir in
diesem jahr vor wie ein zähler zum
weltuntergang schon im januar wird er
als präsident vereidigt und viele fragen
sich wie schlimm wird es werden keine
sorge wenn sie ein weißer rassist mit
pickup truck und einem hang zu
automatischen knarren sind dann kann
2017 ihr jahr werden sicher minderheiten
werden es nicht leicht haben aber da
sage ich selbst schuld
augen auf bei der wahl des eigenen
geburtsortes des geschlechts der
sexuellen ausrichtung und der hautfarbe
ist doch nicht so schwer
ich hab es ja auch geschafft am meisten
freue ich mich natürlich auf die wahlen
zunächst mal in diesem dritte welt land
namens nordrhein westfalen wird vor ort
hannelore sich noch mal durchsetzen und
kommen die wähler überhaupt zum
wahllokal oder bricht ihnen irgendeine
rheinbrücke unterm arsch weg und dann
natürlich der showdown die
bundestagswahl die cdu geht mit dieser
jungen hoffnungsträgerin angelangt
ertl ins rennen konnte ich gar nicht und
die spd kontert mit gabriel oder schulz
das wird ein schneller
so jetzt muss ich aber los die nachbarn
haben mich zum silvester käsefondue
eingeladen
ich hasse käsefondue dafür bringe ich
denen ein tischfeuerwerk mit und danach
gibt's bleigießen mit quecksilber guten
rutsch